[Music]
how does it finally feel to put your
music out there it feels like freedom
jesse Smollett drops his debut album
some of my music available everywhere
March second and only et was inside his
listening party Thursday night how do
you hope people receive your album some
of my music just would love you know I
always say that it's this album being
released it's almost like it's more than
giving birth it's it's it's sending your
toddler off to school you know what I'm
saying you know kids will have the
ability to bully it now you know people
will be able to pick it apart make their
own judgments but it feels really good
I'm proud of the work that we've done it
was a full house at the sailors Club in
LA Jesse's Empire co-stars closest
friends and family all stepped out to
support his musical baby I'm so proud of
him this is more than just a project
this is like putting his money where his
mouth is and his and investing in
themselves for saying you know what I'm
gonna take y'all know and make it
[Applause]
some of my music really represents love
and reflection and freedom freedom to be
whoever the hell you want to be not
taking any prisoners with it and not
stepping on or over anybody but walking
side by side with people so that's what
it is and I hope that people feel that I
do this almost reduced before there was
any show before there was anything there
any songs that were inspired by your
past or present relationship yes
insecurities of course is obviously
inspired by real life they all are but
definitely ha ha I love you is about is
about someone special to me and and
[Music]
are you in love with that special
someone right now very happy thank you
[Music]
and freedom even though it wasn't
written by me it still touches me in a
way that like I break down a little bit
every time that I hit this one note and
it just touches me and and then don't go
it's about my you know my jealousy issue
[Music]
[Applause]
the very first thing I say is I'm like
I'm a real good brother but I would go
through that mother phone in a heartbeat
I just want to say thank you I hope that
are delivered I hope they go enjoy it
just just just
[Music]